-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all doing well
tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we are gonna get to the news.
In his new book, ex-Defense
Secretary Mark Esper writes that
despite his hatred of press
leaks, former president Trump
was "the biggest leaker of all."
Said Trump, "Well, that's
the last time I show him
the Area 51 aliens.
Oh, damn it!
[ Laughter ]
President Biden criticized
Republicans at a fundraiser
last night for their recent
attacks on Disney and said,
"They're going to storm
Cinderella's castle
before this is over."
Oh, buddy, I hate to tell you,
if they're storming anything,
it's the Hall of Presidents.
[ Laughter ]
Also, that's me, right?
I mean, imagine.
That's how I found out
I was a president.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden told
a small gathering
at a Democratic fundraiser last
night that it's gonna be hard
to maintain the majority
in both houses of Congress,
especially since they don't have
it in the first place.
[ Laughter ]
Arizona Senator Kyrsten Sinema
appeared on the Senate floor
yesterday wearing
a pink tie-dyed shirt
that said, "no thanks."
I don't know what that means
except that Arizona elected
a senator who only shops
at airports.
[ Laughter ]
Even weirder, Bernie Sanders was
wearing this.
[ Laughter ]
[ as Sanders ] I need it.
I don't know what to tell you,
I need it.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not gonna apologize.
Mama needs wine.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
President Biden today called
Ferdinand Marcos Jr.
to congratulate him
on winning
the Philippine presidential
election.
Said Biden, "Remember, winning
is the easy part.
The hard part is convincing
everybody that
you actually won."
[ Laughter ]
While speaking yesterday to
thousands of union
electrical workers,
President Biden referred to
former president Trump as
"the great MAGA king."
Okay, can we please not give him
any more ideas?
[ Laughter ]
North Korea reported its first
coronavirus outbreak today
and ordered all cities
and counties to enter
a lockdown or, as they call it,
business as usual.
[ Laughter ]
New York Mayor Eric Adams said
on Tuesday that
his official residence,
Gracie Mansion, is haunted
and added, "I don't care what
anyone says.
There are ghosts in there."
Mm. I don't think that's
who's booing you.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
the top three baby names
that are set to make a comeback
this year are
Joan, Mary, and Margaret,
which is also a full curse
in a Catholic household.
[ Irish accent ]
"Oh, Joan, Mary, and Margaret!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] And fi--
[ Irish accent ]
"I stubbed me toe!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] I've got a
little bit of criticism recently
about my really good
Irish accent.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the New York state
lottery announced yesterday
that the results of Tuesday's
drawing were published
with the wrong Mega Ball number.
And things are pretty awkward at
the house that thought they won.
"Honey, I was joking about
the divorce.
That was --"
[ Laughter ]
"Ha, ha, it's me.
That's when I'm funny."
[ Laughter ]
That was a monologue, everybody.